ces derniers mois les relations entre
washington et ankara était compliqué ce
que certains pouvaient attribué à la
diplomatie made in trump était en fait
plus profond
la preuve la nouvelle administration
américaine n'a pas changé de discours
notamment sur les fameux es400 la
turquie a passé en 2010 est un contrat
avec moscou pour l'acquisition de ses
systèmes de défense antiaérienne de
fabrication russe
de quoi s'attirer les foudres de
washington qui a réitéré ce week-end ses
menaces en exhortant ankara à ne pas
conserver ses systèmes s 400 sous peine
de voir les sanctions américaines
maintenu les différends entre ces deux
pays membres de l'otan ne se cantonne
pas aux contrats d'armement
les intérêts des deux puissances se
heurte parfois ankara estime par exemple
que washington soutient les kurdes du
pkk et les choses se sont accélérées
lorsque 13 otages turcs ont été tués
la diplomatie turque estimant qu'ils
avaient été abattus par ce qu'elle
présente comme des terroristes du pkk
une version que n'a pas suivi washington
dans un premier temps conséquence cette
réponse vraiment de recep tayyip erdogan
qui interpelle les états unis maintenant
il n'y a plus de temps à perdre si nous
ne sommes avec vous au sein de l'otan si
nous voulons continuer cette union avec
vous dans l'otan et dans le monde vous
devrez être sincère avec nous
vous ne serez pas aux côtés des
terroristes et si toutes les parties
vous prendrez le nôtre
après que l'ambassadeur américain en
turquie a été convoqué lundi au
ministère des affaires étrangères turc
la diplomatie américaine a tenté
d'apaiser la situation
anthony blinken ainsi échangez avec son
homologue turc
et voici le communiqué publié par le
département d'état américain qui se
rallie finalement à la position turque
le secrétaire d'état blinken a insisté
sur l'importance des relations de longue
date entre les états unis et la turquie
notre intérêt commun dans le
contre-terrorisme et l'importance des
institutions démocratiques d'une
gouvernance inclusive et du respect des
droits de l'homme
le secrétaire d'état a exprimé ses
condoléances pour la mort des otages
turc
dans le nord de l'irak et affirmer notre
vision selon laquelle les terroristes du
pkk en porte la responsabilité
un exercice de funambulisme diplomatique
pour washington qui doit composer avec
un allié imprévisible il faut dire aussi
que la position du président américain
sur le dossier turc n'était pas y voir
plus clair
en août dernier un entretien de joe
biden datant de décembre 2019 refait
surface
on y découvre bailon particulièrement
agressif envers recep tayyip erdogan
n'oublions avoir une approche différente
pour lui faire comprendre clairement
plus soutenu les leaders de l'opposition
et chez le chien une sortie qui avait
provoqué à l'époque de vives réactions
au sein de la diplomatie turque et qui
pourrait compliquer les relations entre
les deux chefs d'état selon des échos
relayés par la presse américaine
erdogan aurait mal pris le fait de ne
pas avoir reçu pour l'heure le moindre
coup de fil de la part de baden du côté
de la présidence américaine on prévoyait
de se focaliser d'abord sur les
questions intérieures mais joe biden est
rattrapé par l'actualité internationale
et en s'opposant de manière systématique
à la russie dans les dossiers ds 400 ou
encore du gazoduc nord stream 2
washington se heurte à la réalité une
réalité qui fait apparaître les
dissensions qui peuvent exister entre
les états unis et un certain nombre de
leurs alliés